the auto china 2016 in beijing is the
biggest automotive trade fair in china
this year automotive journalists montas
qur'an is amazed at how bustling it is
china has 1.3 billion people and it
seems to him they are all here in
beijing at the Automobile Show to see
the newest developments just like he is
villainously under sean's of the Incas
out to work everyone keeps moving to
avoid traffic jams in the trade fair
halls in the Chinese capital auto China
is held every two years in alternation
with auto shanghai it is an absolute
must for all manufacturers whether
Chinese or foreign
that goes for German carmakers to
Mercedes is holding the world debut of
its long version of a c-class built in
China and intended solely for the
Chinese market the more than five metre
long sedan offers plenty of space and
comfort especially in the rear seats
another Mercedes premiere in beijing is
the new GLC sport SUV well worldwide but
at least as much in China SUVs continue
to be very hot we in the first quarter
on a global basis have seen a growth of
more than fifty percent again here in
China basically the same is true and we
see everywhere this split between
customers being more interested in more
traditional kind of SUVs and the
lifestyle SUVs and of course the coop is
addressing their the letter segment of
customers Mercedes does small as well as
large its subsidiary smart is presenting
the bravos an especially sporty version
of a little city runabout
it's a world premiere for a very special
audi to the new TT RS a sport coupe a
with a lot of oomph under the hood the
five cylinder engine produces a whopping
295 kilowatts
azadi gets bounties board member for
sales and marketing deep mahogany writer
is enthusiastic about the company's five
percent growth in the first three months
of 2016 more and more people are
visiting the showrooms audi is releasing
new models to gain a bigger share of the
chinese market and is optimistic the
interior of the TT RS also has a sporty
design look at the cockpit and the red
stitch bucket seats it's also the
Chinese premier for the new a4l its
wheelbase has been widened to 2.91
meters that's four centimeters more than
in the predecessor model sports car
manufacturer Porsche to as a world
premiere in the capital of the north as
the Chinese call Beijing the Porsche 718
Cayman
in the outside Portia executive Detlef
on platen notes that in the year 2000
his company sold about 200 cars in China
last year the figure rose to 58,000
Austin 50,000 Faso yells Khalifa the
newly developed generation of Porsche
sport coupe a with medium power engine
is more striking sporty-er and more
efficient it's naturally aspirated
6-cylinder boxer engine has been
replaced with a four-cylinder
turbocharged engine the changes in the
718 Cayman are more than cosmetic many
parts of the chassis have been
redesigned
when ameri been here vote out when
Montes sees extinct treasures like this
borgward Isabella behind him he hankers
for the good old days before he was born
and when he sees the new models from
borgward a brand that has been revived
with Chinese money his nostalgia is even
greater back then the Borg Ward had a
unique personality but the bx 5bx 6 + bx
7 looked like every other car today we
expose the execs oda big seed volkswagen
presents its new SUV with a mixture of
show dance and music
t prime concept gte is the futuristic
name of the big new vehicle goddesses
Volkswagen CEO her body says the T prime
anticipates the next generation of the
touareg here it's a plug-in hybrid with
a 50 kilometer range which is very
important for China it has a seating
combination tailored to the Chinese
market it's also the Chinese debut of
numerous technical features like a
curved display gesture control automatic
parking and intersection assistant
everything that vw's new generation has
is in this car to take us most August
day that may be the ideal vehicle for
the Chinese market where SUVs are
rapidly increasing in importance the T
prime concept gte not only has many
innovations the design also sets new
standards especially in the interior all
the systems are controlled by touch
without buttons
but what the Asian manufacturers are
presenting all seems to have been around
for a while the design borrows a lot
from American and European car makers
maybe there's something to the cliche
that the Chinese have no qualms about
copy
so we gave my noise mata says the design
of many of the cars that the Chinese
manufacturers stands is a deja vu
nothing fresh but below the surface the
technology is modern many of these cars
are electric an important feature in a
crowded megalopolis like Beijing but
many many Chinese drivers want an SUV
from their eyes SUV